- [sighs]
- [clears throat]
- CAN YOU TOTALLY CHILL OUT?
- NO, I'M SO ANNOYED RIGHT NOW.
CAN YOU, LIKE, NOT TALK TO ME
FOR, LIKE, A SECOND?
LIKE, THAT'D BE GREAT.
THAT'D BE FINE.
THAT'D BE FINE BY ME.
WHAT?
OH, MY GOD, ARE YOU SERIOUS?
THIS IS BULL[bleep].
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY
BE THE PROBLEM WITH LETTING
TWO MORE PEOPLE IN?
- CHECK YOUR GIRL, BRO.
- I'M SORRY.
- EXCUSE ME, WHAT DID YOU SAY?
"CHECK YOUR GIRL"? UH-UHH,
IT DOESN'T WORK LIKE THAT.
NO ONE CHECKS ME
BECAUSE I'M NOT LUGGAGE.
OKAY? SO YOU CAN GO
[bleep] YOURSEE-ELF.
- MEEGAN, SERIOUSLY,
TWO MORE PEOPLE ARE GONNA
COME OUT IN A COUPLE OF SECONDS,
AND THEN WE CAN GO IN.
- NO!
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE
BEING IN THE GREEN MILE?
- HE WASN'T IN THE GREEN MILE!
HE CLEARLY WASN'T
IN THAT MOVIE.
- WHAT DOES TOM HANKS'S PENIS
FEEL LIKE?
- MEEGAN!
- MOREOVER, HOW DOES IT FEEL
WHEN SWARMS OF BEES
ARE COMING OUT OF YOUR FACE?
- SERIOUSLY, I'M SORRY.
IT'S, LIKE, HER FAVORITE MOVIE.
- DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR ME!
YEAH, THIS IS NICE,
THIS IS NICE.
YOU LOOK LIKE COMMON MEETS
THE INCREDIBLE HULK.
- MEEGAN--
- WHEN YOU BROUGHT
THE FRANKINCENSE TO BABY JESUS,
DID THEY, LIKE...
- OH.
- MAKE YOU STAND
OUTSIDE THE BARN
BECAUSE YOU WERE TOO BIG,
OR DID THEY INVITE YOU IN
WITH ALL THE OTHER ANIMALS?
DON'T FLARE YOUR NOSTRILS
AT ME,
OKAY?
- HE'S--
- DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
HOW IMPOLITE THAT IS?
- HE HASN'T MOVED HIS NOSTRILS
ONCE SINCE WE GOT HERE.
- I SAW THEM MOVE!
- THEY DID NOT MOVE, MEEGAN.
- THEY FLARED!
- MEEGAN, THEY [bleep]
DID NOT MOVE!
- YOUR NOSTRILS FLARED MORE THAN
A SURVIVOR FROM A BOAT ACCIDENT.
- WHAT?
- HE'S NOT EVEN LOOKING ME
IN THE EYES.
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU'RE JUST GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE A LITTLE PRICK,
YOU'RE GONNA GET YOUR ASS
KICKED.
- DON'T TOUCH HIM, MEE--
MEEGAN.
- [scoffs]
CRAZY BITCH.
- [gasps]
[squeaks]
- [sighs]
OH!
- I TOTALLY LOVE MY NAILS
RIGHT NOW.
I'M SO OVER EVERYTHING
RIGHT NOW,
OVER THE FLOOR,
I'M OVER THE SKY, I'M OVER YOU,
OVER THAT PUSSY BACK THERE.
YOU'RE A PUSSY!
- MEEGAN, SERIOUSLY.
- WHATEVER.
- [makes kissing sounds]
- NICE LEGS, LITTLE LADY.
[laughter]
- UM, EXCUSE ME?
- OH, GOD!
- HEY, WHAT DID YOU SAY?
WHAT THE [bleep]
DID YOU JUST SAY?
YOU GUYS COME BACK HERE WITH
YOUR LITTLE ITTY-BITTY DICKS.
- YOU BEST CONTROL YOUR LADY.
- YUP.
- [gasps] EXCUSE--
"CONTROL YOUR LADY"?
NO, HE DOESN'T CONTROL ME,
'CAUSE LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING, I'M NOT A REMOTE.
- MEEGAN, BABY,
CAN WE JUST LET THIS GO?
- NO, I'M TALKING TO THE PUSSIES
OF ANARCHY RIGHT NOW.
- OH, BOY.
- YEAH, YOU.
WHY DON'T YOU ALL
GATHER YOURSELVES,
AND WHY DON'T YOU JUST GO
AND FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO [bleep] ON EACH OTHER'S
LEATHERY PENI.
- HEY, [bleep] YOU, BITCH!
- [gasps]
- OH, NO.
- [squeaks]
- [sighs]
IT'S NOT EVEN THE PLURAL
OF "PENIS."
[punching thud]
- YEAH!
[thugs laughing]
- I'M THE QUEEN OF THE WORLD!
YES!
I FEEL INVINCIBLE!
LIKE I HAVE SUPER POWERS
OR SOMETHING. HA HA!
YOU HEAR THAT,
ALL YOU [bleep] OF THE WORLD?
I CAN DO ANYTHING I WANT,
AND NO ONE CAN STOP ME.
- BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
FIGHT YOUR OWN FIGHTS,
YOU CRAZY BITCH!
- [gasps]
- OH, BOY.
- [squeaks]
- OH, NO.
- [sighs]
UGH! OH.
- NOTHING CAN STOP ME!